now i
[Music]
had the time of my life
and i owe it all to you
oh man
and we'll see if anybody shows up to
this live stream i have no idea if
anybody's even gonna show up at all oh
there we go chocolate ice what's up
yo
i don't know why i act like nobody's
ever gonna show up to these streams man
you guys show up and you all start going
crazy look at this chat start going nuts
man this chat's like it's it's funny
like if i could personify this chat when
it first fires up it's just like uh
uh
yeah it's a party like
that's basically what it turns into but
um
yeah yo what's going on guys
it's been forever since i've done a live
stream
yes it is or yes it has it's been a long
time
i'm singing yes i am
but uh yeah how are you guys doing
everybody everybody let me know let me
know how you guys are doing you guys
doing good you guys not doing good
hopefully you guys are doing good you
know hopefully you guys y'all are doing
awesome i need to get me some dinner by
the way drink it like a protein shake
heck yeah man i got like three more days
until the orange juice goes bad so
i gotta do something
um no no so so d23 is happening um on
saturday uh at like 11 a.m my time i
think but over at geek culture explained
i am going to be uh basically streaming
my live reactions to d23 so i'm testing
out the stream by just basically do a q
a with you guys and just just seeing
what you all think so um how is how's
the audio quality
how's the how's the how's the audio
quality guys is the audio quality good
is it is it bad how's the audio quality
by the way we're probably only gonna do
this for about maybe half an hour or so
but uh but yeah so hopefully it's not
too echoey on on obs you're kind of
limited at least i'm kind of limited to
options i do have like third-party
pieces of software that i could use but
like obs keeps crashing every time i do
so i just uh i don't use it but
yeah do a flip
[Laughter]
oh man you're going to d23 that's
awesome
audio is good audio solid perfect
awesome my voice is beautiful
i should read you all bedtime stories
i seriously gave thought to the idea of
launching a youtube channel where i just
read people bedtime stories like that's
i literally gave thought to doing that
but uh yeah
uh
audio is straight and they held that
comment for review
youtube's weird
but uh
yeah so on on par with my ordinary
recordings awesome
no need it sounds great
good enough
no one expects the rob core
oh man do it yeah i don't know if i were
gonna do something like that i would
probably launch it as like uh like a
podcast first you know and then maybe
transition to youtube videos i don't
really know but
a slight echo yeah that's that's uh
there's not a whole lot i can do see if
if i were able to use d verbate which is
the audio um the audio vst that i
normally use to get rid of verbation you
wouldn't hear anything because like in
the videos that i record right now i'm
recording in this setup here right now
like there's no sound treatment at all
like i'm literally in just in my
basement um but i can use deverberry and
it just clicks that that reverb out just
in an instant right literally just
remove reverb and make it i'll make a
few adjustments in terms of of the
settings i want to make it sound better
but because it's a little heavy-handed
when i first use it but
yeah so uh so let's talk about comics
let's talk about colors this is a q a
right this is a q a you guys send me
emails all the time with questions you
guys always want to know stuff and now
that we're here for a q a all you guys
are doing is just saying you love me and
i i love you too i love you too
i do
i really do
i love you
l
o v e
love
this is creepy this is very creepy
[Laughter]
oh man
jason statham as cathone
ooh
no
i would never choose jason statham miss
cathode honestly i think there are
characters he could play that are just
far more interesting than catholic like
i really really think there are um i
would not cast him for them uh axe is
getting epic it really is isn't it like
i was reading through that comic with
exodus and i was like bro like i love
exodus man because you never really get
to see him go off you never really get
to see exodus just lose his [ __ ] in a
comic and it was just one of the coolest
things oh
i guess
you never get to see him lose his mind
it's just one of the coolest things that
you get to see so
um
all the time yeah magneto yeah he's
amazing that's one of the things to
worry about man like when magneto gets
mad
that's what that's when you know things
are about to pop off man that's when you
know things are popping off so
um am i stoked for wakanda forever man
let me tell you something dude i am so
excited you know it's going to be a tear
jerker right you know there's not going
to be a dry eye in that house by the
time that movie comes to an end or when
they do like when the movie does the
whole segment where they do like a
send-off because they'll probably end up
having like a a wakandan funeral for
t'challa which i think is going to be
the sort of in movie meta commentary on
like basically the farewell to chadwick
boseman just the cast and crew of the
movie basically paying their respects
through the film there's not gonna be a
dry eye in that house when they do that
whole that whole segment people are
going to be crying right and i'm
probably going to be right there with
them man
that's exactly what it's going to be man
just just those tears coming down man
it's going to be rough but outside of
that i'm ex i'm so excited for that film
namely the submariner the rumor about
the post-credits scene which i'm not
gonna spoil but yeah there's there's i'm
i'm so excited for that film i'm so
ridiculously excited for it right it's
just gonna be
amazing um what was with donnie blaise
and she-hulk a johnny blaze reference i
mean i guess donnie blaze doesn't exist
in the comics uh well see i don't know
it's kind of a mixed thing because in
the comics right now in the ghost rider
comics right now
i think they established that johnny
blaze has a brother but they haven't
gone in depth into it if by the way if
you're not reading the ghostwriter
comics right now you are missing out i
need to cover it too the current
ghostwriter run is insane it's
absolutely amazing it's just a
ridiculously good story uh but yeah so
i'm not i'm not really sure
uh what the whole deal is with donnie
blaze but in the end like i'm kind of
getting bored with she-hulk right i'm
just kind of like all right i mean it's
a show that exists but i'm also not the
target demographic for that show so
that's fine with me but uh black bolt
does still suck black bull will always
suck because because he's black bolt
[Laughter]
uh no super chats i mean i have super
chats on here i think i'm not entirely
sure
um
but uh i mean if you really want to
donate you can go check out patreon if
it means that much to you you know
patreon.com comments explain shameless
plug uh if you really want to you know
but i mean honestly i just like being
able to talk to you guys if super chats
mean that much to you i guess i can turn
super chats on
um
which i don't know how i do that
uh
oh crap
i just i just put an ad in
i just for those of you guys who have
youtube red you probably didn't see it
but i literally just put an ad
in the middle of the stream
oh man
uh
let's see let's see if viewers start
dropping that's how i know that like
they
like they that i put an ad in yeah we
lost like 20 people so yeah like i
accidentally put an ad in so that's my
bad y'all like people are just like and
we're done with the stream now and they
just they just leave they just go do
something else like the the power of
advertisements on youtube uh damn we
lost like 40 people because of that ad
they just they just bailed they just
totally bailed out
but uh super chats is not on okay i
don't know how to turn on
uh super chat you know i'm not gonna
worry about super chat i'll worry about
super chat another time but uh but yeah
man um ads kill viewership and youtube
videos
they kill that audience retention man
but um but yeah so what are my overall
thoughts on face for
oh well now we're getting the viewers
back um that's a good question uh that's
a good question what are my thoughts on
on phase four
you know
yeah i i accidentally put an ad in i
didn't mean to i thought i was hitting
the super chat button and then like i
said insert ad and i was like oops
but um
but yeah so hold on a second let's uh we
gotta
ban this person forever
uh report
uh
report there we go
okay
and
yeah we're already we're starting to get
spam bots in here
see okay okay here's something here's
something that i also want to clarify
here because people have been sending me
emails about this
i will never leave a comment in a
youtube video telling you that you've
won something right if i say for if for
example i'm giving away uh rob four
rings right i will post like i will like
say it in a video like i'm giving away
rob four rings you know send me an email
or something like that but i'll never
post a comment doing that the thing
that's going on here right now and it's
affecting creators all across the
youtube platform youtube's basically
been overrun with bots in the comments
and in fact they actually steal like
they take the profile picture of the
person who's whose channel they're
spamming and they copy it so it looks
like that person spammy now the name
obviously is not comics explained so the
name is kind of a dead ringer that it's
not actually me
but um youtube doesn't care like it
doesn't matter to youtube at all they
don't they kind of don't want to do
anything about it oh there's a lot of
different theories as to why that's the
case some people are saying that it's
because um it adds to youtube's overall
viewership because each bot counts as a
view and so if they get rid of all those
bots it'll actually make it it'll reveal
the true numbers of how youtube's
performing as opposed to the numbers
they give to advertisers so having those
bots make youtube look good um some
people say just youtube just doesn't
care it doesn't matter to them because
uh it's not really preventing any
viewership it's not causing a huge drop
off in viewership so if the money's
there youtube doesn't care um so i'm not
really sure what the the motivation is
behind it um all i know is people have
been complaining to youtube for months
and youtube just won't do anything about
it so that's that's basically why that's
happening uh so yeah i will never leave
a comment and tell you that you won a
ps5 that's that's never me it's never
going to be me i would never do that i
think it's kind of silly so if anything
just uh just spam youtube on twitter
blame youtube right for for just not
caring enough to wanting to do anything
about the uh about the bots that are
plaguing their platform so it's just the
results of what happens when a company
has a monopoly right they just
whatever happens happens and that's just
kind of the way to do this
but um
but yeah so i you know i don't know when
it comes to phase 4 in the mcu
to be quite honest with you guys which
by the way if you guys are enjoying the
stream make sure you drop a like
everybody in the stream right now drop a
like on the stream just just drop a like
on the stream just just do that
just just like the stream and and like
i don't know let's let's do something
ridiculous in this stream right um
um everybody spam d23 just type d23 just
spam d23 just just just do that i don't
know why
i think that's just an awesome idea just
spam d23 right like i'm i'm just i just
i just want to see that i just want to
see everybody like the stream and spam
d23
i think it would be uh i think it would
be awesome to see right just just a ton
of d23s coming through but while you
guys are doing that um
yeah as far as uh i love to see it i
love to see it right just all these d23s
oh god there's like a zillion of them um
you know as as far as phase four goes
i can't be the only one that feels this
way phase four kind of feels like filler
content now it didn't initially right
loki and one division and so on and so
forth it didn't really feel like filler
content but it kind of does now right
she-hulk's not a bad show it's a comedy
show there really isn't much in the way
of easter eggs right i mean it falls
right in line with like the old uh john
burns she-hulk run and even dan slot to
a degree but it's just not necessarily
for for me right so i'm not overly
digging it too much if anything i think
that phase four was sort of marvel just
kind of delivering us content while they
kind of go back to the drawing board and
figure out like what comes next right
it's it's sort of the equivalent of like
busy work right like just here's some
stuff to do and here's some stuff to see
that may or may not have anything to do
with anything right kind of do a little
bit of world building with like doctor
strange two and so on and so forth but
uh by and large like we're focusing on
the important stuff over here
we'll be back when the important stuff
gets sorted out right i kind of feel
like that's sort of what's going on with
with phase four um it kind of feels like
that at the moment at the moment but uh
but yeah i don't know having said that
have you guys heard the rumors about
john boyega
and uh the character he's playing in the
mcu have you guys heard the rumors about
that
do you guys wanna you guys wanna know
what the rumors are saying because it's
kind of a big deal it's kind of insane
um it is all world building kind of but
like she-hulk that's the thing like a
show like she-hulk for example doesn't
really offer any meaningful contribution
to the mcu right it doesn't really do
anything to build anything in the mcu um
it's just a character who's there right
uh and like that's it right she made it
like literally they could they could
like kill she-hulk off at the end of the
show and it probably wouldn't matter all
that much um because they haven't really
done anything to build her up yet she's
just a lawyer out there and just doing a
thing and like that's it um if they do
more with her that would probably change
especially they do it in films but for
right now like
literally she could just get shot in the
face at like the end of the show and
like people are just kind of like okay
well i mean that happened and like
that's it that's the end of she-hulk
so uh so yeah i don't know but um
but yeah you haven't heard a word uh
yes please okay there's a lot of people
who are saying yes a lot of people who
are saying yes
so the rumor here
rumor
rumor
rumor
not confirmed
is that john boyega is playing richard
ryder
in the mcu he's playing nova that's the
rumor man now i don't know how i feel
about that because i've been saying for
a long time
i would rather see sam alexander than
richard ryder because sam alexander is
fun he's young he's vibrant he's like a
space-faring version of spider-man right
like that's that's the thing like that's
that's that's what i want to see like i
want to see i want to see that right i
would absolutely love that but um but
yeah i'm you know i mean richard ryder i
mean he has had some awesome moments
right he's one of the only superheroes
to climb mount gamora and come back for
seconds right so he's he's not somebody
to scoff at right he's not somebody to
scoff at but uh but yeah so that's
that's the rumor on on what's going on
with uh with john boyega so no one cares
about nova i mean people said the same
thing about iron man until they made
iron man 1 and now everybody cares so
yeah that's kind of a ridiculous
statement to make but uh yeah you want
sam he has a better story he has a
better story yeah sam has a great story
i love the story of sam it's just it's
phenomenal
but um
but yeah uh you rather see him as
thrasher what
you want to see him his knight thrasher
i mean i guess
uh
yeah i i guess um
this is the man behind the voice yes
this is this is the man behind the voice
i i am
comics explained
yes
[Laughter]
i am i am comics explain um
let's see uh how would we feel if hugh
jackman was the one to come out and
announce deadpool 3 deadpool kills the
fox first okay that'd be kind of amazing
like
deadpool 3 is basically him killing the
entire fox verse deadpool kills the
marvel universe
i would love that i would absolutely
love that i think it would be just
freaking hilarious if that were the case
uh i don't know if it is but i feel like
it would be hilarious why would we get
sleepwalker in the mcu
i mean sleepwalker in the mcu is kind of
cool like he is he is an interesting
character but i don't know why we would
get sleepwalker in the mcu fassbender is
dr doom okay here's a question would you
rather
would you rather see michael fassbender
return as dr doom or see michael
fassbender return as i'm sorry would you
either see michael fassbender play
doctor doom or would you rather see him
return as magneto
which one would you rather see i
definitely want to see the sentry in the
mcu
yeah i definitely want to see this entry
in the mcu
um d23 starts tomorrow the marvel
studios panel is not until saturday
which is really the only thing any of us
care about so uh i mean there's video
games and stuff you know but we're
actually we're gonna make a video that
covers a bunch of video game things and
so on and so forth but we like i
definitely want to do live reactions
like me and the staff we're gonna be
doing or at least i'm gonna be doing
live reactions to uh the marvel studio
panel of d23 so i'm really excited about
that um philly automatic rob you the
bleeping man thank you
[Laughter]
thank you um oh wow i'm getting kind of
a kind of a mixed response here to be
honest with you guys some folks are
saying they want magneto some folks are
saying they want doctor doom
honestly it looks a little more mixed
than i thought it would be
to be honest with you guys i figured it
was just going to be like magneto like i
thought that was all it was going to be
but i mean some people are saying they
they want him to show up as doctor doom
uh
i don't know man if i had to choose a
character from michael fassbender to say
i'd want him to come back as magneto
he'd be a really cool doctor doom but i
would want him to come back as magneto
because he had some cool moments as
magneto but imagine what michael
fassbender could do
as the master of magnetism
under the leadership of kevin feige and
like the mcu
as opposed to fox like imagine what that
magneto would look like like i i really
want to see that uh what about raymie
malik or cillian murphy as doom see
silly and murphy doesn't he doesn't seem
like imposing enough you know like i
think of silly and murphy and it's like
dude i could i could be that guy's ass
like i mean that's that's i mean i
wouldn't he seems like a really cool guy
you know and i'd love to talk to him
sometime but um but you know what i mean
like like there's a there's are times
when you look at like an actor and
you're like okay but like if i could
beat that guy up could i really see him
as like a credible villain doctor doom
is one of those villains where like he
has to show up on the scene and just be
imposing you know what i mean like like
he has to show up on the scene and just
and it's just like damn
you're like like when thanos showed up
right i mean like you saw thanos and he
was just enormous and imposing and it's
just like god that guy's huge man like
dude he would be the crap out of
everybody but uh doctor doom kind of has
to be the same way he has to be imposing
but arrogant at the same time that's
kind of my thought so
no i couldn't necessarily see cillian
murphy as as doctor doom like i don't
really see that
um
oh no i'm not saying he has a bad resume
i mean silly and murphy's played some
really really cool characters right he
was amazing as scarecrow in in the nolan
batman trilogy he was phenomenal as
scarecrow but i don't know i just i have
a hard time seeing him as doctor doom i
don't know it's just
i don't know
see i would rather have jon ham play
cable if i were to pick him to play a
role in the mcu i'd rather see him play
cable or potentially like william
striker or um
i don't know maybe like stephen lang
or bolivar trask i'd rather see him play
one of those honestly i think he'd be an
amazing william striker but there's no
way the marvel cinematic universe makes
a movie uh where they literally
have a religious evangelical christian
who thinks it's his mission from god to
like annihilate mutants no way they make
a movie about that they piss off like 80
percent of america right like none of
the old people would go and see the
movies even though i don't get to go see
them anyway but like it piss off all the
christians right they'd be protesting
that movie it'd be absolutely insane um
but no like that's that's that's not
gonna happen
um you'd like brian cranston to voice
doctor doom brian cranston would play an
amazing doctor doom especially okay how
many of y'all how many of you guys here
how many of you all here have seen
breaking bad
almost said the walking dead how many of
you all have seen breaking bad give me a
yes if you have seen breaking bad
because if you have you know that by the
end of that show
when walt stops being walt and becomes
heisenberg that like he would have been
an amazing doctor doom like he looks
like he would have been a great doctor
doom or he would have been a great mr
sinister nathaniel essex he would have
been a great essex in uh in the mcu or
even in fox it doesn't really matter um
do i like jojo's bizarre adventure i've
never seen jojo's bizarre adventure
never seen one episode i've heard of it
but i've never
never seen people like of course
[Laughter]
yeah of course i've seen that yeah no uh
it was a great show and he would
definitely make an amazing an amazing
doctor do like he absolutely would it
would he would he would have made a
phenomenal afternoon okay so here's a
question here's a question right like
see it'd be cool if we could have like
kaiser sose in the mcu like just i mean
kind of like the concept of kites or so
say how many of you guys ever saw the
usual suspects
right give me give me a yes say yes if
you ever saw the usual suspects
um
jojo's bizarre adventures like why did
everybody keep talking about jojo's
bizarre adventure what's the deal with
jojo's bizarre adventure i don't
understand it i don't i don't i don't
get it
but um
kim kardashian is miss fantastic no
no
absolutely not
um
you want a proper apocalypse
yes i'm totally down with that
i would definitely want a proper
apocalypse
i would definitely want a proper
apocalypse
okay so a lot of people are saying yes
to the usual suspects okay for those of
you all who never saw the usual suspects
right it's a phenomenal movie there's
there's this guy kind of like the man
behind the scenes named kaiser sose
right he's just sort of like this guy
where nobody really knows what the deal
is now he is in the movie and you find
out who kaiser associate is at the end
phenomenal ending to that film just
phenomenal ending to that film but um
but yeah so so
there's a point where they tell the
story of kaiser sose right and they and
like the story is being told in saying
that like he's either german or he was
like turkish or hungarian nobody knew
for sure but what they did know is that
at some point in the past these
hungarian mobsters these hungarian guys
wanted to form their own mob and they
knew that in order that the the true
basis behind power was not like guns or
money or anything like that it was being
willing to do what the other guy
wouldn't do and so they targeted kaiser
sose and so they went to his house and
basically they waited on him and did
things they probably shouldn't have done
but when kaiser sose got there he
basically finds like his wife and his
kids just screaming right now this this
is this is when it gets dark right so
cover your children's ears cover their
cover your children's ears mommy and
daddy so here's here's what happens
right
so so these guys so show kaiser so say
they mean business they like
off his daughter on the spot right in
front of him and so they're like we want
your money we want your business we want
it all right we want everything that you
have so kaiju so say in order to show
these guys that he means business
uh he takes out his he he takes out his
own son and his own wife in front of the
mobsters right just just off some right
there and then he kills all the mobsters
except for one and he leaves that guy
alive to go and tell the story now when
this guy's family is like dead and
buried right when his family's in the
ground this guy goes to work right he
targets the mobsters he targets their
families right he kills their kids kills
their their their parents he kills their
parents friends he kills their friends
he burns down the houses they lived in
he burns down the businesses they worked
in and just like that the guy's gone
he's just he just disappears goes
underground like nobody knew where he
went to but it's one of the one of the
craziest stories ever but if you could
take that concept and apply it to like a
character in the mcu if i'm being honest
with you guys man i would want to see
that guy like i would want to see that
dude like it would be absolutely insane
but uh my studio is so clean and crisp
yeah what do you guys think about the
artwork back here what do you guys think
about the artwork back there dominic
toretto in the mcu yeah he's got he's
got family
family yeah no i would not want to see
even diesel's apocalypse if i could
think of then diesel playing a character
in the mcu i could see him playing a
ghost writer
right i could see him playing a ghost
writer i think that would be interesting
uh michael jai white would be an amazing
blue marvel uh honestly before chadwick
boseman i always advocated that um
michael jai white play black panther i
always thought he would have been an
amazing black panther because he's like
he's like a black belt in like seven
different martial arts right the guy's a
legitimate fighter right i mean his
acting chops probably need a little bit
of work but i would say that like
overall michael j white would have been
a phenomenal
black panther in the mcu so
um
the artwork looks great yeah i'm glad
you guys like it
as soon as i saw it at san diego i was
like i got to buy this i can use this as
a set piece
so
uh blackboard wolf is cool
uh no one's ever said that i assume
you're saying it in sarcasm that you
don't actually mean it because nobody
means it when they say that
um
it's like dark multiverse the punisher
yeah it really is it really is some
frank castle level stuff man that's a
punisher level stuff it's kind of nuts
but uh
chris hemsworth for wolverine
michael j white would have made a really
cool blade too he would have made a
great blade actually you know what i
think he i think that they they should
have hired him for blade now having said
that mahershala ali that guy's got it
man like that guy right there i love
watching mahershala ali films so i have
no doubt he's going to be phenomenal in
that film uh
still man if there's any one thing i'm
the most disappointed about when it
comes to the blade film is that it's
rated pg-13 blade needs to be rated r
man the wesley snipes version was rated
r and this needs to follow suit it has
to be an r-rated blade anything short of
that it's just it's a half measure right
it's got to be r-rated so okay guys uh
we got a few more minutes plus my
laptop's gonna die soon so uh
we got a few more minutes on this stream
we'll we'll uh we'll we'll answer some
questions that a lot of you guys have
but um
but yeah what which movie uh rudy the
one with kaiser sose um that was the
usual suspects
it was a phenomenal movie it's one of
the best movies you're ever gonna see
it's it's just ridiculously great phase
seven annihilation wave okay that would
be legit the annihilation wave in phase
seven i would 100 be down for that i
would absolutely love that
um
dogma uh who do i think okay so so let's
let's go because now the questions are
rolling in now the questions are all are
all coming in so um just a curiosity who
from the boys other than anthony starr
can i see in the mcu with major roles
ooh
with major roles
um
if they don't have jon ham play william
striker um
my god who's the guy that plays billy
butcher uh that guy got his i i i
always feel terrible because i always
forget his name
um but that guy like i would have him
play uh play billy butcher in the mcu uh
he would i'm sorry not billy butcher um
william striker in the mcu he'd be
absolutely amazing god what what is his
name guys i always feel so terrible but
like i should know what his name is it's
such a unique name it's such a unique
name and like
oh my god
carl urban that's what it is thank you
thank you okay you know what uh
gerald gerald mo mohabir send me an
email you're gonna rob four ring thank
you you're amazing uh yes okay so uh yes
it would be it's carl urban i would have
carl urban play william stryker in the
mcu he would be phenomenal in the marvel
cinematic universe um
carl urban's not in the mcu who did carl
urban play in the mcu he hasn't played
anybody in the mcu
oh he was scourged that's right oh man i
forgot about that oh
oh well you're still gonna you're still
going about quitting for that but but
yeah i totally forgot he was scourge oh
yeah i totally forgot about that
um rob will they give the vampire green
blood to avoid the r rating i don't know
i have no idea no idea how they're gonna
treat that but uh yeah i don't know
let's see um
uh rob would you ever cover the
berserker comics by keanu reeves on
comments explain i actually haven't had
a chance to read them yet so i don't
know if i'd cover them um i haven't had
a chance to look at it so i do want to
check it out uh rob quick question what
actor would you want to play johnny
blaze ghost rider and which story would
you like to see adapted in a movie me
personally the road to damn nation yes
the road to damnation that's exactly the
story to pick either that or just the
main damn nation story arc and just roll
on the midnight suns and call it a day
right because it's literally a team with
the midnight suns um
who would i pick to play johnny blaze
ooh
nicholas cage no i would not bring
nicholas cage back uh it'd be
interesting it'd be funny but i would
not bring nicolas cage who would you
guys have play ghost rider in the mc
would you pick nicolas cage would you
choose nicklaus cage to play ghost rider
um
[Music]
god if i were gonna have anybody play
ghost rider in the mcu
you know who i would pick i would pick
uh joel edgerton i would have joel
edgerton play uh play ghost rider i'd
have him play johnny blaze i think he'd
be amazing either that or danny ketch he
looks more like a danny catch than
johnny blaze but i'd have him play one
of those guys so
um norman reedus would be a great choice
but i think norman reedus would have a
better choice to play like mephisto
or somebody like that
but um
yeah norman reedus would be he'd be he'd
be a great choice uh let's see jerry
jerry seinfeld is ghostwriter we'll see
the thing here
like what are they doing you know
they're they're torturing souls down
there in hell i tell you you know it'd
be it'd be kind of weird it'd be goofy
norman reedus okay if you could have
norman reedus play anybody besides ghost
rider in the mcu who would you have him
play i'm gonna flip the script i'm gonna
ask you guys a question right if you
could do that who would you who would
you have him play okay we have time for
one more question we have time for one
more question and i gotta bounce over
here i gotta get some food and uh and
start wrapping my night up but we have
time for one more question
uh what's this question gonna be submit
your questions as fast as you can get
those questions in
and uh yeah
we'll uh
we'll answer this last one and then
we'll call it a day
so yeah norman reedus would be an
awesome mephisto he would be an amazing
mephisto he would also be a good
wolverine that's a good point
he would be he'd be a good wolverine i
mean norman reedus is kind of old but
that's the thing though i mean he's he
could he could play a character for
another 10 to 15 years i think depending
on how long they wanted to do it karna's
would be a great choice for norman
reedus i didn't even think about that
norman reedus is carnage bro that would
be absolutely amazing
uh
okay
let's scroll through these questions as
they're being spammed in here uh
let's see
do i think the mcu
will reboot
oh what a question
do i think the marvel cinematic universe
will reboot
yes and i think they've already planned
it and i think it's already in the
process of happening and i think it's
going to be a soft reboot more than a
hard reboot right here's what i think is
going to happen i think the multiverse
was brought back because of everything
going on in wanda vision loki and all
that kind of stuff um what i think is
gonna happen here
right what i think what i think is gonna
take place
with this whole thing right the way that
the marvel cinematic universe is gonna
reboot it's gonna happen exactly like
this
it's gonna be
ill